okay and that's how it looks like on the  google pixel xl pixel 3 xl  you can see that the notch is quite big  but you can actually remove it like most  phones  these days you have a notch  so you need to go to developer options  and you scroll all the way down  where is it it's quite far down down  there there you go simulate the display  with a cutout  and so right now it's default  how they look like when we click hide  screen oh okay that was fast  about let me try a display corner corner  hide up  not quite different  what's the difference  okay that's weird  there's a cutout here now  doesn't quite really work  let's try different one double display  cutter  seems to be lagging  looks no different from the original  let's try the last option  tall display cutter  no difference  let's go with default again  looks the same  but let's go with height instead  it looks so much better actually the  pixel 3 xl  there you have it  to simulate a display with a cutout  okay